in our health watch here at 4 o'clock
about 10 000 children will be diagnosed
with cancer this year in our country and
the life-saving treatments they receive
can be incredibly challenging especially
for kids so here's one little girl's
story
[Music]
four-year-old bridget has spent much of
the last 15 months at a specialty cancer
center receiving treatment for rare
childhood cancer called rhabdiosarcoma
this has been going on for you know a
third of her life but i mean she pretty
much does it all with a smile and she's
just really brave she started chemo
right after diagnosis reducing the tumor
so doctors could remove it she also
needed six weeks of radiation five days
a week which for children often requires
sedation the most important part is that
that child is staying still because of
any sort of movement the radiation will
go in the wrong spot sedation means
anesthesia multiple times a week with
fasting starting the night before it
also means more time at the hospital
but certified child life specialist
sydney sanford helped bridget avoid all
that armed with toys she's a friendly
face for young patients making it all
less scary nobody can be in the room
with the patient during radiation sydney
wanted to see if bridget would be able
to avoid being sedated she gave her a
pair of noise canceling movie goggles
she picked out barbie to watch i always
say stand like a statue
and so they'll lay down like a statue
and she did great cindy was just a rock
star kind of like calming her down the
hospital says she's one of the youngest
patients to receive her radiation
without sedation i call her bridget the
brave and she's most definitely brave
and bridget's doing great she's in
remission and finishes chemotherapy next
month
isn't it so tough to see those little
kids and they're so brave they're so
strong four years old yeah the american
cancer society says that childhood
cancer rates have actually risen just
slightly over the past few decades but
they've got these great technology
advancements to help a lot of the kids
but unfortunately those numbers aren't
going in the direction we'd like them to
see